in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Rob and
Maria are with us hey guys how are you
we're great welcome welcome good to have
you where are you from the Detroit area
oh wow yeah nice flight down to
Nashville did you drive we drove that's
a bit of a haul yeah about eight hours
okay very cool well I here to do a
debt-free scream I assume yes and how
much have you paid off about two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars oh there we
go
how long did that take yeah thirteen
months or so okay I'm feeling a story
and your household income during that
time I made about seventy thousand and
Maria made about thirty five thousand
and Maria also had a online business in
which she made a hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars in addition yes oh nice
that little side business of yours yeah
doing rather well okay so you're up over
200k then mm-hmm which kind of explains
part of this but did you is there a
house and this what was what kind of
debt was this it was student loans one
hundred and eighty thousand dollars
worth of student loans and for law
school and then I had a house at the
time that I had a seventy thousand
dollar mortgage on okay and what did it
sell for I sold it after we sold it at
about a hundred and twenty thousand
after all the closing costs and it was
the seventy in debt reduction included
in this 250 though yeah all right so a
hundred half of it was the house sale
overall then yeah because the equity
came towards this plus the debt was
reduced on the mortgage all right good
but still in thirteen months you pay off
one hundred twenty seven thousand bucks
pocket making two hundred and some
change
Wow so who's the lawyer I am okay cool
cool so this was a lot of US law school
debt then all the student loans was law
school debt yes okay all right and then
the house and what else that was it that
was it those two things okay
so what happened thirteen months ago
that let you guys on fire I mean this is
amazing
uh-huh we got engaged all right so we
had to get out of debt to get married
and all that kind of stuff all right
made you start talking about it now
you're married now obviously yes okay
when did you get married in June okay
all right so been married about nine or
ten months then over the thirteen and
started working on it before then so
whose idea in the engagement process was
this who was mine
okay I had done FPU about seven years
ago on my own and I was step free and
saving for retirement and saving for a
house and then we got engaged and I knew
he had a lot of debt and he knew I had
savings and we needed to figure out what
to do with it so we sat down and made a
plan and Rob handled the house stuff on
his own and he kind of saved up and
threw anything he could out of his own
budget toward the debt and we decided
that you know we were still engaged so
we wanted our income to be separate so
the plan was I was going to take all of
what I had been saving for a house and
instead of getting a house right away
we're going to throw that at the debt
and I was going to just keep working as
hard as I can on my business and keep
saving that money and so as soon as we
could were married we heard a giant
check before we went on our honeymoon
for a hundred and ten thousand dollars
and then there was um maybe about a
little under 20 thousand left and we
just worked really hard over the summer
to pay the rest of that off yeah perfect
very cool so that's a different way to
get at this it's not your normal story
but it's a great story so Rob she comes
to you and she says I went through this
class I got a big pile of money and you
a big pile of debt so you're gonna
listen to me I mean how did this
conversation go
it was Maria broached it very nicely
actually she was like well we're getting
a change nice you've got this you've got
this you know I I really had never
budgeted before done anything like that
you know I wasn't you know stupid with
my money but you know I wasn't actually
having a focused plan for him so she
told me about FPU and we decided you
know as part of our premarital
premarital counseling stuff to watch it
together and it was phenomenal
I loved it thank you very much thank you
very nice very cool well it's good
pre-marriage counseling because if you
can get on the same page about this did
you notice that you get on the same page
about other things automatically kind of
all of our goals are just aligned no
once you decide where the money's going
it pretty well lines up everything else
mm-hmm I think that's why people fight
about it so much on the other side is
they don't have the they don't have
goals that they've agreed on but once
you lay that out and now caution with
this great income and you just being
been married a year you don't have any
payments in the world
no just rent that's wacky I mean you're
gonna save up to pay cash for a nice
house pretty quick yeah that's the goal
yeah how long you think it'll thank you
well if we save up and do it all in cash
we figure it'll take about three to five
years okay all right the rate you guys
are going that's probably faster than
that hopefully been on the price range
and all that very very well done how
does it feel amazing yeah it's wonderful
Nate Nate how old are you - 34 and I'm
32 perfect okay well done guys I'm proud
of you thank you excellent job and
thanks for coming down all the way from
Detroit to share your story in person
very very neat Rob and Maria Detroit
Michigan area 250,000 dollars paid off
that includes the sale of a house but
man they cash but most of it 13 months
at 200k income count it down let's hear
a debt free scream 3 2 1 we're debt-free
very well done love it love it love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim